Y
WERE THREATENED.
CHARLIE KIRK, GREAT TO SEE YOU
TONIGHT.
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> TUCKER: THE FOUNDER AND
EDITOR OF COMPACT, HE SAYS THE
PROBLEM IS DEEPER, NO
CORPORATION SHOULD HAVE THIS
MUCH POWER OVER OUR FREEDOM TO
SPEAK.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON
TONIGHT.
THAT WAS MY SUMMARY OF YOUR
VIEW.
TELL US, WHAT DO YOU CONCLUDE
FROM THIS?
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME, TUCKER.
THE GREAT DANGER IN WHAT WE HAVE
SEEN, WE SUSPECTED IT, OF
COURSE, ALL ALONG BUT NOW WE
HAVE CONFIRMATION THAT SHADOW
BANNING WAS HAPPENING, GREAT
DANGER IN THIS ISN'T THAT OUR
FREEDOM OF SPEECH IS EXPRESSED,
ALTHOUGH THAT'S HORRIBLE AND
THESE PLATFORMS IS WHERE FREEDOM
OF SPEECH LIVES OR DIES, BUT
THAT THE PROCESS THAT ALLOWS
ELITE OPINION FORMATION IS A
SEALED OFF BUBBLE.
RIGHT?
WE HEAR, FOR EXAMPLE, THAT
VLADIMIR PUTIN DOESN'T HEAR
ALTERNATIVE VIEWS ABOUT HIS WAR
STRATEGY IN UKRAINE AND THAT'S
WHY HE MAKES BAD DECISIONS.
THE SAME THING HAPPENS THROUGH A
STATE DIRECTED MECHANISM IN THE
UNITED STATES AND ACROSS THE
WEST.
IT HAPPENS THROUGH PRIVATIZE
CENSORSHIP THROUGH ENTITIES LIKE
TWITTER, FACEBOOK, ET CETERA, IF
OUR ELITES AREN'T WILLING TO
LISTEN TO DISSIDENT VOICES LIKE
DR. JAY, AS WE NOW KNOW FOR
SURE, THEN THEY DON'T MAKE GOOD
DECISIONS, RIGHT?
BECAUSE THEY ARE CONVINCING
THEMSELVES, THEY ARE SEALING
THEMSELVES IN A BUBBLE, NOT
ULTIMATELY THAT DIFFERENT FROM
THE KIND OF BUBBLE THAT, YOU
KNOW, A QADDAFI OR A PUTIN
CREATE IN A DIFFERENT WAY IN
THEIR OWN SORT OF COUNSELS OF
DECISION MAKING.
THAT'S THE SCARY PART OF THIS,
THE ELITE THEMSELVES ARE
STRUCTURALLY TURNING THEMSELVES
INTO BUBBLE BOYS.
>> TUCKER: INTO WHAT THEY SAY
THEY HATE.
I WONDER, I DON'T KNOW THE
ANSWER BUT COULD RUSSIAN MEDIA
BE MORE CONTROLLED THAN AMERICAN
MEDIA IS?
MAYBE, BUT MAYBE NOT.
>> YES, I MEAN, IN 2020,
OBVIOUSLY I WAS WORKING AT "THE
NEW YORK POST."
THAT CONFLUENCE OF CORPORATE,
BIG TECH, DEEP STATE, BLUE CHECK
MEDIA, ALL WORKING TOGETHER, YOU
SAW THAT.
IN A WAY IT WAS SORT OF MORE
TERRIFYING BECAUSE THERE IS NO
CENSOR OF POWER.
HEY, IT'S THIS ONE PERSON, WE
CAN APPEAL THROUGH THIS
RECOGNIZED PROCESS, WHICH IS
WHY, TUCKER, WE STILL NEED TO
INSIST ON SECTION 230 REFORM.
THE REASON TWITTER AND FACEBOOK
AND YouTube AND ALL OF THESE
OTHERS GET AWAY WITH THIS IS
BECAUSE OF A LAW IN THE 1990s
THAT WAS DESIGNED TO HELP THEM
CENSOR THINGS LIKE PORNOGRAPHY.
CALLED THE COMMUNICATIONS
DECENCY ACT.
THEY ARE USING THAT, ABUSING
THAT NOW TO ACT LIKE PUBLISHERS
BUT WITHOUT BEARING ANY OF THE
TRADITIONAL PUBLISHER'S
LIABILITIES, AND SO THAT HAS TO
BE CHANGED.
IF YOU AND I LIBEL SOMEONE IN
THE PRINT OR MEDIA, WE FACE THIS
KIND OF LIABILITIES, AND THEY DO
NOT AND THAT'S WHY THEY GET TO
CENSOR.
THEY GET ACT LIKE WORLDVIEW
PUBLISHERS BUT WITHOUT BEING --
BEARING ANY OF THE TRADITIONAL
PUBLISHER'S LIABILITIES.
THAT NEEDS TO CHANGE.
I'M REALLY GREATFUL, GOD BLESS
ELON MUSK BUT IT'S NOT JUST ONE
COMPANY.
IT'S THESE OTHERS AS WELL.
THEY ARE MONONGA